ça c'est un porte avions doit au milieu
d'un ascenseur on met l'avion dessus et
décembre c'est bien ça orange une
citrouille tu te raconter à ma confiture
de fraises aux escargots de bourgogne
elle est excellente
limonade orange dégâts tout
tient bon jour vous arrivez en plein
boom la fête bat son plein excusez-moi
j'ai à faire regards citoyens comme il
est beau eric géométrie sa garde bonjour
messieurs 10 nov bonjour monsieur le
président je ne supporte pas d'entendre
ce mot veut pas entendre ce que disent
les grincheux grincheux mois alors ça
six mois chemin gages sont vraiment des
ménages de sombrer notre passage est
rien du tout pardon monsieur le
président ce noyau de tous elle vous le
rendra service monsieur le président je
dois aller de ce côté-ci vérifié chez
les affiches de la fête ont bien été
posée et d'autre part j'ai rendez vous
ici même avec le photographe pour qu'il
fasse mon portrait alors ce n'est pas
trop vous demander qu ils vous attendent
c'est cela merveilleux ma très chère
amie vous avez d'unités légende d'une
rapidité exemplaire pour tout à l'heure
pour être honnête ça va être trop laid
de quoi parles-tu casimir je n'imagine
rien de plus n'est qu'une photo de
monsieur du snat maintien justement
voilà le photographe messieurs
mademoiselle je vous salut bonjour salut
salut dites-moi est-ce que cette pause
l'aïr a
préféré ça a peut-être non alors ça
c'est très gracieux en effet mais je
suis ici pour photographier le président
ira que vous l'attendiez mais très bien
je l'attends litres soyez gentil prenait
quand même une photo d'eux kazimierz ça
lui ferait tellement plaisir monsieur du
snob sera furieux non mais je me
chargerai d'éloigner tout les
photographier ça vous laissera le temps
de faire un cliché de casillas est
d'accord m
je bête à bien l'écouter c'est que je
désirerais conserver sur mon clichés
l'ambiance de la fête non mais vous
voulez me mettre au milieu tout le monde
ne verra pas non non non non non c'est à
dire que je veux tout le monde dans le
fonds et vous ici devant très gros plan
c'est à dire qu'ils seront dans le fond
mais en tout petit et vous votre visage
devant en très gros c'est parti c'est
affreux
voilà vos plans
ne bougez pas
parfait merci un bonjour merci beaucoup
vous fait passer les clichés dès qu'ils
seront prêts tenait bien sûr merci
beaucoup dit mme solis nabawi julie et
moi nous voudrions vous montrer quelque
chose
oui c'est fini ce n'est pas trés le
jeune marc dujardin fait rien je vais où
il faut cela fait partie de ma fonction
windows
quoi qu'est ce que c'est casimir venez
vite ça qu'est ce qu'il est je vais vous
prendre une photo oui mais mais ce n'est
pas possible par avec cet appareil
maintenant mais pourquoi qu'at-il mon
appareil mais parce que après le gros
plan que vous avez fait de monsieur du
snop toute la pellicule doit être abîmée
vous n'allez pas croire cette légende ma
pellicule est en excellente état bon ne
bougeait pas voilà comme ça ça va oui ce
sera une photo superbe rhin non ça ne va
pas mais qui est il encore je voudrais
un gros plan a comme monsieur deux
hommes n'ont plus gros
non non non encore plus gros donc encore
encore non je voudrais pas très très
gros plans oui mais jeu est trop près
mais non c'est ma foot ou alors ça ne
paie rien allez allez avancer encore
encore encore écoutez c'est encore
encore encore vous l'aurez voulu
oui mais ce sera un vrai gros clan voie
là
oh lalala lalala
mais qu'est ce qu'il fait il est en
retard il m'avait promis de me porter ma
photo des faits serait prête mon sens
quasi nulle a dit mir t'énerve pas comme
ça il faut du temps tu sais pour
développer une photo batié d'ailleurs
voilà le photographe à voilà votre photo
casimir 1 comme je vous l'avais dit pour
un gros plan c'est très gros plant
qu'est-ce que ça la pellicule était
mauvaise non mais casimir a voulu un
tellement gros plan que je n'ai réussi à
photographier son ventre
mais merci quand même au revoir au
revoir eddy dont casimir comment vas tu
faire tu voulais vendre ta faute aux
enchères aussi mes pieds je suis venu
assister à cette vente comique à vous
voulez acheter la photo de casimir je
mets mon ami jamais je n'achèterai une
photo de ce monstre et ça je vous le
promets quoi moi un monstre aux petons
voit la photographie non elle n'est pas
encore là ah dommage j'aurais bien ri
mais qu'est ce que ceux ci
mais où avez vous trouvé ça ce tableau
abstrait est admirable c'est un
chef-d'oeuvre de l'art contemporain
je peux l'acheter ben si vous voulez
bien 200 francs ça c'est fait non
205 je peux pas t'empêcher de marchander
toi tiens merci et 5 5 font sous les 5
voilà merci pour mes amis je vous laisse
je vais mettre ce chef-d'oeuvre chez moi
vous me donnerez le nom de fu qui
achètera la photo de casimir si vous y
tenez monsieur les snobs avec plaisir la
boule promesse que tu vas faire de tout
cet argent est bien
puisque mon ventre est un chef-d'oeuvre
je vais acheter un cadre pour l'encadrer
[Musique]
drame pas mon voilà le pot de miel ici
le fromage est très bien là l'os de
seiche et puis là les petites noisettes
très bien
tian bonjour à vous si vous êtes en
train d'observer casimir je me demande
bien ce qu'il est en train de fabriquer
avec tous ces produits
et bien il ne me reste plus qu'à
installer mais étiquette elle met
pancartes bon d'abord celle là
là
par mon papa mon papa papa papa remis
par le pam pam pam pam voilà parfait
distributions gratuites de nourriture
pour les animaux
et 20 pour une fois c'est une bonne idée
photo epa
voilà bien bien bien d'abord
l'écureuil
qu'est ce que put bien manger un petit
écureuil j'adore les petits écureuils
qui vont dans la forêt par un matin de
soleil printanier quand le il ya des
reflets roux dans la fourrure a bien
pour moi l'écureuil va adorer ce petit
poisson
voilà
casimir se sent l'âme bien poétique
aujourd'hui vous trouvez pas moi je suis
pas persuadé qu'il ait une bonne notion
d nourriture préférée de chaque animal
bon le poisson rouge au un joli petit
poisson rouge qui montent et descendent
dans son aquarium dont le fond est une
symphonie de petits graviers
multicolores qu'on va manger mon petit
poisson ces carottes voilà il va adorer
ces petites carottes
la
la ça s'arrange pas bon et le lapin aux
j'adore les petits lapins qui vont dans
la forêt avec leurs longues oreilles et
leurs petits que pointue toute blanche
bon mon ami lapin va je pense beaucoup
aimé
ce bel os de boeuf
voilà
dix mois casimir qu'est ce que c'est et
bien tout d'abord je te féliciter bras
d'eau c'est très bien cette distribution
gratuite de nourriture pour les animaux
c'est une bonne idée n'est ce pas
excellentes et moi c'est monsieur du
snob
le président de la fête quitte à donner
tout ça oui il m'a demandé d'aller au
magasin est de ramener la nourriture
préférée de chaque animal et ben c'est
vraiment très bien tu as peur jamais je
n'aurais cru capable d'un acte aussi
désintéressée oui pour une fois je n'ai
pas pensé à moi pour une fois bravo mais
quelque chose ne va pas qu'ils aient mis
en avant quoi bien écoute je n'ai jamais
vu un écureuil manger du poisson tu
crois mais oui de même aucun des
poissons rouges que je connais ne
mangent des carottes j'en connais
beaucoup et bien suffisamment pour te
dire que la carotte n'est pas leur
nourriture préférée à ces affreux si je
me suis trompé tous les animaux vont
être déçus mais nova temps fait par an
les enfants vont nous aider casimir tant
mieux venez avec moi venez avec moi on
va également meilleurs sont là
mettez-vous devant son comptoir là
vous êtes tous là regardez ce qu'il ya
sur la table pour casimir apporter
toutes ces bonnes choses pour les donner
aux animaux c'est gentil de sa part mais
malheureusement il ne sait pas quels
sont les animaux qui ment chacune de ces
bonnes choses ou les biens qu'on l'aide
vous mettez la grand mère d'abord on
passe en revue tout ce qui est sur le
comptoir de casimir
qu'est ce que c'est que ça les enfants
vont s'éteindre cette annonce un gros os
de nos sa moelle et ça qu'est-ce qui est
là dedans ça c'est écrit
grain ce sont des crustacés d'eau douce
qu'on appelle des puces d'eau beaucoup
minuscule bien un bon qu'est ce que
c'est que ça
c'est un poisson à poissons tout frais
ça
sont des bonnes carottes après quasiment
des noisettes sur l'assiette
du fromage du gruyère
et au bout la barre
comment s'est-elle et l'os de seiche le
sec 10 mois et demi qu'est ce que cette
boîte là ça c'est rien ça c'est à moi
c'est
rien faut pas y toucher bon bah écoute
j'insiste pas je veux pas être indiscret
casimir je vois que tu as préparé des
étiquettes à la première qu'est ce que
c'est l'intérêt pour le la alors d'après
casimir le là peut
changer ça fait rêver je me suis
complètement trompé le lapin moche des
carottes tuvache les prix sont rangés
la sirène les poissons rouges mange des
daphnies sainteny des puces d'eau et
l'éclairage
l'écurie manche des noisettes dues à
d'autres étiquettes mais voilà les
autres voilà tient alors qu'est ce que
tu vas te donne tu as canada marie
canaries alors
voilà le retient casimir dont celle de m
voilà arrangements que tu vois là pour
m'aider il se fait le break les canaris
sur l'os de seiche comme ça
m'a souri
alors là sourires l'amorçage le fromage
les souris sont très payante de froid
mal d'années de guerre et tous les
autres fromages
le soyez gentils et garder du haut
niveau parce que vous cachez de cacher
la tricherie et les animaux qui sont
chez eux alors que mon jeune ours dit
tu vas au bout du comptoir poser ton et
nieppe pour l'ours voilà un si c'est ça
insolite casimir
alors d'accord
et ensuite le chat voici le poisson
et ben voilà casimir mais dis donc
maintenant tu pourras peut-être nous
dire ce qu'il ya dans cette boîte olaya
ya juste quelques bananes écrasées avec
de la confiture de fraise et du lymphome
est un petit peu de moutarde et une
saucisse de toulouse tiède mais cru
comment tu as deviné non feint que du
mur c'est le gloubiboulga le plat
préféré des casimir us ben oui non tu
vois je me suis dit que peut-être un
casimir eu sa femme et passerait devant
mon stand et faut que je n'ai que du mur
tu sais très bien que tu es le seul
casimir us à venir dans le jardin et
puis ici ya que toi qui aimes le
gloubiboulga ben ouais et alors oh que
du mur
à